soon some of you will try to make let
her babies designer babies where parents
can pick I color as well as things like
intelligence and height already some
people pay labs to examine embryos and
pick the one with the DNA they like
people choose the gender and screen for
diseases but so far you've been limited
to harvesting genes that exist naturally
but that will soon change for the first
time Chinese scientists use new
technology to alter DNA in human embryos
the design babies are supposed to be
immune many diseases home Jian Quay says
the twin sisters were born with the
immunity to HIV he was put under house
arrest
Sheldon krymsk II who was advised our
government about genetic engineering
since the Chinese are right to punish
that scientist there's absolutely no
justification for creating a eugenic
Society most Americans agree there's a
poll here on designer babies and asked
whether it was be okay to boost
intelligence 83% say taking medical
advances is going too far
of course they say that philosophy
professor Jason Brennan says people
always resist new medical innovation
when you have any kind of intervention
into the body that's new people think
it's icky and they take that feeling of
akina's and they moralize and I think
it's a moral objection I would like to
have a child not a robot and I
understand if you want to protect I mean
where does it stop you know and I think
the other thing is there should be
things that we leave up to God to the
universe
one of the bush daughters telling me
that God doesn't want it I'm not really
sure I'm gonna take her word for it if
God appears before me and says don't do
this I'll stop but why would God say
stop we already give our kids music
lessons braces tutoring karate lessons
any advantage we can why not also give
them better genes imagine he says the
world where people are much smarter
maybe smart enough to avoid wars to take
us to other planets and other things we
can't even imagine maybe we'll turn them
into x-men what objection to customizing
babies is that it first only rich P
but we'll be able to pay for it this is
gonna be a new way to create disparities
in wealth but every bit of technology
that we enjoy today follows the same
pattern you look in your automobile and
you have a CD player an mp3 player and
GPS all of these things when they first
became available we're incredibly
expensive the rich pay the
infrastructure to develop the
technologies and then they spread and
they become commonplace for everybody to
have cassette player or GPS system
people can live without but if some kids
are smarter and taller and faster that's
just really unfair but we can make it so
that everybody is healthier and have the
rich get raised first they do get raised
first and then they pay for everyone
else to be raised second rich people got
a lot of things first airplanes LASIK
surgery then the prices come down even
if this price came down for this it
would create more injustice if some
people are better we're all better off
for it Einstein's existence helped
everybody you can't use the argument
that because we've had technological
breakthroughs that have helped people
that every single effort on using
technology is going to help people
you're just against change you're on all
these committees the government you just
want to stop progress unless you give
permission you're an old fuddy-duddy I
love change I but I think that there are
some boundaries you know there are some
things that shouldn't be shouldn't be
fuddling around with most countries now
have laws banning creation of designer
babies but it's still going to happen so
say here in the US where you're not
allowed to buy a kidney if you need one
that doesn't mean people don't buy
kidneys they just go and buy them
elsewhere banning this kind of
technology will just guarantee that it
will be available only to the super-rich
and only to the politically
well-connected it's gonna happen anyway
somewhere well if it does it doesn't
mean it should happen in the United
States once other people start doing
this we'll all feel we have to to keep
up it's not so clear why that's a
problem if everyone is making their kids
healthier and
stronger and smarter and have less prone
to disease and you feel social pressure
to go along with that good shouldn't you
do that as a parent for your child I
would I want to use science to help my
descendants be all they can be